رشاقه امازون تستوجب اقاله الاف الموظفين
الاخرين في مواجهه المخاوف الاقتصاديه
المتزايده القول هنا لصحيفه التي اكدت بان
الشركه ستقيل تسعه الاف موظف خلال
الاسابيع المقبله بهدف طبعا جعل الشركه
اكثر رشاقه واضافت ان عمليات تسريح جديده
ستؤثر بشكل كبير على الموظفين في فراق
الحوسبه والاعلان وفريق توفير حلول
التكنولوجيا بالاضافه طبعا الى منصه تويتش
للبث المباشر الرئيس التنفيذي لشركه
امازون اوضح بان الاقتصاد غير المؤكد وعدم
اليقين دفعهم الى تقليل التكاليف وعدد
الموظفين ولفت الى ان التخطيط السنوي
لشركه امازون كان مدفوعا بالرغبه في ان
تكون اصغر حجما وان اتخاذ هذه القرارات
سيتم بين منتصف واواخر المقبل هذا وكانت
امازون اعلنت في يناير انها ستتخلى عن
اكثر من 18000 موظف من قوتها لما له من
فوائد طبعا على الشركه على المدى الطويل
وفق تعبيرها
[موسيقى]